Good evening.
Good evening to Good evening, sir. Good evening, sir.
Good evening. Good evening, sir.
Good evening.
Okay, present my screen. Let's start now.
Okay. Uh
Uh Okay. Last
class. Yeah.
So if I remember correctly, in the last class, sir,
had introduced, uh, this
greedy wise, unsupervised
and, uh, layer wise training, greedy, layer wise training,
unsupervised, unsupervised.
That is how the people have tried during the 2006.
And on that is what was presented, right?
And that was first thing.
And then followed by that, we covered
a little bit on this and in module,
and I had shared these two for your practice, that, okay,
what are the, what is the N module?
Some of the notebooks were integrated into that. Okay.
So this is what is the quick recap from the last
class, uh, right.
So, uh, what I will do, uh, in this particular session that,
uh, I will start from this slide, uh, anyway, some
of the slides, which, uh, I have already given you
for the practice, this you have to practice by your own.
But whatever concept is covered in these, uh, notebooks,
I'll cover with, uh, this, uh, one, one of the huge cases.
Okay? So that is what I have planned, so
that you will have the quick revision also,
and if you have practiced, then you can ask the questions.
Also, if you have faced any problems.
So this is what I have planned.
So today it'll be mostly the HandsOn, uh, session
where you will see the PY codes,
and with the PyTorch code, we'll try
to understand some concepts as well.
So that's the plan, what I have for today.
So before that, before I'll start those things.
If you have any quick questions, you can ask me.
Otherwise, I'll take you
through those use cases for the PyTorch.
Yeah,
anything, anything to be asked.
Have anyone tried practicing these notebooks?
Oh, okay.
So if there is no question, so then I will start then.
Okay. Alright.
So, uh, I'll start with this slide,
but then I'll cover some
of the topics from the previous slides,
slides also with the code.
Okay? So in PyTorch we have something called
as dataset and dataset loader.
Okay? These two are the class in the PyTorch.
It is, these are, these two are the abstract class,
which is defined in the PyTorch.
And these, these classes are very important
because we know that in the PyTorch, uh, we have
to present the data in the form of tensor.
Okay? Usually what happen when you read the data in
pandas, or you can say the mpa,
then your data is in the form of Aries or list, okay?
But the S accepts only the tens as an input.
So what these two class will help us, it, uh,
with the dataset class, we'll see that it helps us to decide
how you want to load the data.
Suppose you have the data in the CSP file, then
how it'll be loaded and
how it'll then be converted into the tensors.
Or suppose you have a data in the, say folders.
You have the image data, okay?
And folders, one type of ms, a cat
and another folder, another type of ms a dog.
Now you need to load that one.
So all those, uh, uh, ways of loading the data you can
actually do with the help of this dataset class,
which is already defined in the pipes.
Okay? Now, along with
that dataset class has few more functionality.
I'll quickly talk about that as well with the examples.
Similarly, there is something called dataset loader
class, okay?
Dataset loader class.
What it does, once you have defined that,
how will you load the data dataset loader class
quickly creates the batches out of that.
Because ultimately, if you have very long data,
very big data, then you will create the mini batches, right?
So one of the work of the dataset loader class is
to create those mini batches
and then retrieve those batch wise data
from the dataset class.
Okay? So that's how dataset loading
and dataset the creating creation of the batches.
These two are two separate tasks, which has been hand,
which, which is being handled
by two different class in the S okay?
That is how these two classes are defined.
And now I'll show you the use of these two as well.
So what is the motivation?
First of all, neural networks do not operate directly on raw
data like CSV images text.
So you need to convert the data into some standard form,
say 10 form.
Now, this data set and data set loader are core abstractions
in PyTorch that decouple how you define your data
from how you efficiently iterate over it.
So dataset class is meant to defining your data
that talks you how you want to load the data,
how many samples are there in the data,
and also it returns you the particular row if you will ask.
But dataset loader class will tell, okay, how
to create the batches
and how to irate over those batches, that that's
how these two classes are different
by their function functionality.
Okay? So you can see that here,
dataset class has three required method,
and I, I'll show you that also in the code.
It has first method as this is this, this, this is the
signature of constructor, okay?
In the object oriented programming in Python.
So you write the constructor like that,
it's a special function, but, but
because it is in it, in it is used as a constructor, okay?
And, uh, I have told that in my previous, um, notebook, uh,
when you must have seen this one, that constructors are,
constructors are functions,
but they get automatically executed
whenever you will create an object
of, of a particular class.
I'll show you that one. So basically this is a constructor,
this is one function in it, which tells
how data should be loaded.
There is another function in the data assist class,
which tells how many number
of samples are there in your data, see
how many rows are there in the csv.
So that is what, who will return this length function.
And then finally we,
it has one more function called gate item.
So based on the length function,
then later data loader class will decide how many,
what is the, uh, batch site, what are,
what will be the data set, uh, in one batch,
how many data set will go.
All those things will be decided by this length, function
and get item will return you one row.
If you'll give, give an index, say that. I'll ask 10.
I'll put here 10. So it'll return with 10 through
the feature of that row as well as suppose there is a label,
so feature label both that will return by this gate title.
So these three are the main functionality
in the dataset class.
Fine, I'll show you the codes of all these things,
and this is how we are going to see this.
Uh, so anyway, so this is my dataset,
is my custom dataset class, okay?
And it is inheriting the dataset,
which is the abstract class.
So it is inheriting the property of the, uh, dataset class,
which is already defined in Python.
And this is my constructor.
This is the length function, and this is the get item.
These three are the methods.
So you can see that the constructor except two parameter,
uh, if, uh, cell, uh, three parameter self X and Y.
So X is my feature, Y is my label.
And what it does, it converts those X
and Y into the tensor. So features are,
But you must be meaning why is the tar, um,
the output on label, you said?
What do you mean, sir? YY label as in
Label as in suppose you're doing classification problem,
then it'll be like class one, class two.
Okay, so sir, output, uh,
Yeah, output input.
Output, yeah, output is
There. Okay. Okay, sir.
Yeah. So, um, that is X and Y.
So what we do usually in the s what happen,
your data should be of the tensor type, as well
as your features should be of the flow type.
That is what we are doing here.
In fact, uh, there is, okay, second,
uh, some change.
Okay? Anyway, I'll do that one, I'll do that
and I'll show you this later.
There is one change here,
Okay?
Alright. So, uh, I'll quickly show you
that this code also, so
that you will understand it
It's, so let me present here.
So I'll show you.
This code here should be, uh, here,
the label should be in the type of the long here.
I mentioned 4 32, but I'll change that one, no problem.
Then other method I set, this is a length method,
which will simply return in your whole data set.
How many rows are there? So what are the length
of your data rows, okay?
And gate item will return that route.
Whatever I index number, you will give,
it'll return you the X, that is feature y,
that is label, okay?
So that is the work of the dataset,
whatever custom dataset class you are creating.
So, uh, data loader class, then it'll simply take the data
and it'll create them into the mini batches.
That is the main work of the data loader class.
And how does it work? So suppose you have data loader.
Data loader will take first parameterized dataset,
which you have just created, okay?
And then batch side will take
with this batch side will create the mini batches
and will shuffle the data
before creating the patches so that the same type
of data should not come or sequence data should not come.
It should be a variations of the data.
Similarly for the test loader.
So, so this is the main work
of the dataset, uh, loaded class.
I'll show you that. And finally, what we do is
with this dataset and dataset loader class,
we create our training loop
because we have to say that I trade, uh, we have
to perform the training, say that for n number of epoch.
So in this loop, you can see that we have the epoch epoch.
We can decide how many number of epochs we want to run.
So for each epoch, it, this whole loop will run.
And what you do, you take the data
and batches from train loader or test loader.
Here in train loader, we extract the X batch, Y batch.
And then for that, we do all those thing for
forward processing
or whatever it is, uh, loss calculation, backward processing
or, or weight adaptation.
All these steps we do for that batch,
and then we go for the next batch.
Okay? So this is how it'll,
so if you see the pipeline view, we'll have the data.
We'll first load the data using the dataset class,
then we'll convert the data into the mini batches using the
data loader class.
And then we'll go on
for the NN model will feed these batches into the NN model,
calculate the loss, update the parameter.
Now this is whole pipeline, which we are going to see next.
Okay? So what I have done is I have taken one, uh, use case
to show you all these demo,
but building this neural network model, uh,
I have taken this, there is one Kaggle data set called
Fashion AMS dataset.
Okay? So if you go to the Kaggle, okay, Kaggle,
Kaggle fashion amnesty.
So amnesty data set, all of you know that, uh,
AMS data set is a popular 10 class data set
where your visit there is an image,
and each image is,
is representing the dig value zero to nine.
So there are 10 classes for zero to nine.
This, uh, fashion adminis data set is developed on the same,
uh, with the, with the same idea,
but now instead of having a digit as an image
or input, you'll have fashion product image here.
Also, there is an image data,
but the input, rather than having a digit 1, 2, 3, 4, like
that, you have some 10 different fashion
product as you can see here.
So I'm going to show you the demo based on
this itself, okay?
So in this, if I'll give you a little more
understanding about this data.
So fashion amist is a data set of gray scale clothing images
designed as a drop in replacement
for amist, but more challenging.
So, uh,
the MS size here is 28 cross 28,
so total 7 94 pixels in each image, gray scale.
So one channel training sample, 60,000 test sample,
10,000 number of classes, 10 task drive, multi-class class.
And these are all the type of the data.
Some of images are of t-shirt, top, trouser, blue, uh,
like shirt back, all those things, right?
So one question, um, number, uh, these test samples
and the, this is standard, or I mean
It is given in the, uh, in the data
Set itself, Data set itself, if you go to the data,
Okay? And
it is given, see that dot csv file
for the test mm-hmm.
Hmm. In this, if you'll see there are 10,000 domains,
Okay?
It's given in that part of the data itself.
Okay? Thank you. Okay.
So yeah.
So what I've done is I, I have, uh,
created one neural network for this,
for this multi-class classification problem
where we have 10 classes,
and this is the structure of the neural network, which I,
uh, which I have created, uh, with this,
I'll show you quickly, but we'll have the input layer
where we'll have the 7 84
because we are using so far the
artificial neural network, A and n.
Okay? Uh, we'll see that the same dataset,
how we will use when we'll go
for the CNN convolution neural network, which we are going
to learn from the next class.
But, uh, with the a NN first, I wanted to show
that's why all these, uh, things.
So this is the a NN architecture.
All inputs are connected
with all neurons in the hidden layer one,
all hidden layer one neuron connects with all hidden neurons
with the two, and similarly with the output.
So here the dimension is 7 84,
because your each image is represented by 7 84 pixels.
So what I will do, I'll read those pixels rather than
reading the image, I'll read those pixels, okay?
That is one thing later with the CNN I'll show you how
to read the image, okay?
But same dataset would be there.
We'll see that in the hidden layer, 1 1 28 neurons.
That is how it is kept here in the hidden layer,
2 64 neurons, and in the output layer 10 neurons,
because there are 10 classes right now in the hidden layer,
the activation functions, which we'll use is relu,
and at the output layer, the soft max,
because we have to do the distribution, one of the,
the neuron will show the final class, okay?
This is the setting in which we are going
to develop our neural network architecture.
Fine. Okay? Let us dive into it.
So what I have done is, first of all, let me this go, go
to the other notebook, uh, here.
Okay, so what I've done is to start with, uh, here,
if you see the, uh, uh, here, if you see this, uh, notebook,
I have also given the dataset now, okay?
So here, there is a link of the notebook
and below that dataset, so you can
use this dataset when you will do the practice.
Here, what I've done is that I have taken a sample
of the data, sample of the data,
and I'll be working only with a sample of the data first,
and then I'll show you quickly the all 60,000 data,
whatever I have, okay?
In my, in my train. So first of all, from the Kaggle, uh,
where there was two files, fashion test, CSV trained,
I'm using only train CSV only, okay?
Because in the test csb, uh, miss, I'm, I've not utilized,
but you can use it for your case.
So in the train CSV also I'm on,
I have created only a sample data
and that, uh, with that, I'll show you first how it works.
Then we'll do it for the complete dataset. Okay?
So, so what I'm doing is,
although I've given you the link when, uh, when you will
do the practice, you have to utilize that link for my case.
What I've done is I have downloaded that sample, uh, here,
this one f fashion
SCO small csv.
This is the data, and I am just, uh, uh, just,
uh, uploading that data in this session.
Okay? I could have done it using the Google drive also,
which I'll show you later on.
But here, I'm just uploading that data, that's all. Okay?
So this data is available now with me, right? Okay.
To start with, what I'm doing is I'm just importing some
of the packages from Panda Psychic Learn, okay?
Torch mat, plot link.
These are all the packages which I'm importing.
Now, this line is only to set the manual seed so that
whenever I will, uh, do the train test split,
I'll be getting the same set of data shuffled random,
but same set of data for the input
and for the, sorry for the test
and train so that I can reproduce the
whatever result I'm getting this time next time as well.
So this is the line for that.
Uh, here, uh, I'm using pandas to read my CSV file.
So my data is in the form of pixels. I said 7 84 pixels.
Each image is 28 across 28, which is represented
as 74 pixels.
So I'm reading the CSV file, which is in the form of pixels,
not as, that's why you saw
that your data is in the form of CSV.
If it is an image, it'll not be in the form of CS V. Okay?
So it's the CSV data, uh, essentially.
So here, if you see this, if I'll run, uh, uh,
there are five rows, sorry, five rows,
because this is what it is showing,
but, uh, you can also have the,
you can also see the complete data if you wish.
So here you can see that there are 6,000 rows
and 7 85 columns.
This is a sample data. Total data is 60,000. Here.
I'm only using six, 6,000 rows just
to start our experiment, 7 85 columns,
because first column represents my label
or output, whatever you say,
where the labels are going from zero to nine, okay?
10 class and rest. All are my pixels.
So rest all are my features going from pixel number one
to pixel number 7 84, okay?
If you'll go all the way, it'll go all the way up
to pixel number 7 84.
You can see that. Now, this is what I'm, what is my data?
So just to understand, yeah,
this data are representing some kind of image.
Now, this piece of code, what you're seeing is to
just present few images.
So here it is presenting 16 images using the map plot clip.
We are, what we are doing is first 16 images.
We are trying to just plot that, okay? What are those data?
We have the first image are, uh, this,
and it's labeled is nine second image.
Is this there shoe? I guess. Then label is seven.
This is T-shirt label is zero, bag eight,
likewise fashion products, okay?
Uh, and then it's labeled,
it's given actual data is not image.
Actually data which is given in the CSV file is this pixels,
but I have shown you just to understand that,
and they are all gray skill image,
although it looks some colors and all, but they're all gray.
Skill means build black and white images are there,
because my pixel value, if you will see it goes from zero
to 2 55, and we have a single channel in the colored image,
we usually have a three channels,
but here we have a single channel.
So it's a, okay.
Now, next, next thing, what I'm doing here is, uh,
just doing the train test split
and converting them in the form of a dot values.
So what I'm doing is, I know that first column is for label,
and next 7 84 columns are for features.
So I'm just using df, I lock
and using all the row comma
column number will start from one,
and it'll take all the column, obviously,
because first column, which is zeroth column
by index is for the label.
And from the first index onwards up to seven 84th,
uh, index, uh, 75th index, uh, 74 index are my features.
You can see here, right? So zero, I'm not considering,
I'm starting my features from fixel one up going up to 7 84.
That is what it is happening here.
So it is starting from one, two, whatever we have now
that is x, that is going to be my feature.
So I'm putting into, into x
and from the same df, I'm only selecting the zeroth column,
all the rows, but zeroth column.
So that will act as my label
because only first column, which is zeroth column, uh,
by index is my label.
So this is what I'm doing.
First XY I am finding
and then converting this XY as train and test.
So train test is split
because I'm not loading another file for the test,
although I could have done, but here I'm,
what I'm doing is from the same x
and y keeping 20% as a validation or test,
and 80% as a train.
Okay? So I, again,
I'm using train tester split function from psyche learn.
All of you are aware about this next line
of code is also familiar, but we are just doing some scaling
because my pixels values are going from zero to, uh, 2 55,
as you can see, two 13 here, here, two 13.
Okay? Likewise, some values are zero somewhere,
so it's in the, the range is very high.
What we are doing, we are just normalizing that
because we know that machine learnings are good if you will
give the normalized data, so divided
by the maximum number will gimme the, uh, value
between zero and one.
So that is what it is. Now, you can see that x, uh,
all the pixel value is between zero and one.
Okay? So that is what is happening in this scaling.
The features train feature, also test feature,
also XX strain X test represent the features
for train and test time.
Similarly, y train y test represents here, Y train
and Y test represent here the labels at the test time, okay?
Uh, okay. Now what this is until this,
I guess there is no problem, and we have seen these codes
many times before as well.
Now I'm, I'll be showing you how
to create this dataset class, custom dataset class, as well
as the data loader class, okay?
Which we were just discussing earlier.
So as I said, first of all, we create our class name,
which is a custom data set,
and this inherits the properties of the dataset class
of the pipes, okay?
Now, as I said in the last class, also you,
we are using a concept of object oriented programming
where we have a class and we are going
to make its object, okay?
Later on. But here, while, uh, defining the class,
in the class, what we have, we can have the, uh,
we can have some, uh, methods.
So all these three are methods in it is a method,
length is a method.
Get item is a method. The three methods in this class, out
of these three in it is a special method
because it is, it is, it is a constructor.
Okay? This, uh, this is a signature of the constructor,
and constructor are those method, uh, which is special
as compared to the other method in your class,
because the constructor will get automatically called once.
You will create the object of this particular class, okay?
Automatically, you don't, you don't have
to call them if you want to, if you want the length
to be executed, you have to call them, right?
But constructor need not to be called.
It gets automatically executed. That's why it is a special.
So this is the representation of constructor.
We are, and in the constructor, usually what we write,
usually we write those thing in the constructor,
which we want to get automatically executed.
We don't want user
to decide whether I want to call it or not.
There are some functionality in, in,
in all softwares, right?
Where you want to give the user control
and you don't want to give the user control.
All the things are there, right?
So constructed are something which
will automatically get called.
Users will not have the control on that one minimum.
It's maybe the something minimum, which is, uh, which is,
uh, automatically get called.
For example, suppose you go to the ATM, right?
Some software, uh, sub software, um, backend, it is working.
As soon you will insert your card, what will happen,
it'll get connected with your account, okay?
And few functionality get automatically called.
Like say that what is the balance in your account?
Uh, although you can,
there are some functionality which it offers you to select,
like whether you want to see your balance, whether you want
to withdraw some something or whatever it is, right?
Likewise, pension change and all,
but there are some other functionality.
The connecting with the database means banks, uh, database.
That happens automatically.
So those functionality you want
to keep in the construction, okay?
Connecting, connecting with the databases,
backend functionality and all you want to do it,
otherwise it, you don't want
to give those control to the users.
Constructors are being useful there where you want something
to get executed automatically
whenever some trigger comes, something like that, okay?
So in this case, whenever you will create the object
of this class, this method which automatically get executed,
and what we are doing in this method here,
we are taking two things, features and labels.
We'll take it, uh, later, I'll show you
this constructor receive, it's a method,
so it'll execute something.
So it'll accept features and label
and it'll convert them into the tensor.
Right now it is doing that towards dot tensor takes the
features, convert them into this particular type,
then takes the label towards dot tensor
and convert them into the long type.
That's all. And then save it in again,
the same variable name, features, and label.
Please show, uh, this, uh, calling this function, uh,
this constructor wear so that we can match it.
I'll show, I'll show it. Let me explain.
I'll come, I'll go to that part.
Okay, sir. So this is the constructor fine.
Now there are two more functionality here.
That is the length function, and then get item function.
So what this length will do, it'll simply take the feature
as an input, okay?
And it'll count what,
how many rows are there in that particular feature.
So it'll simply return how many rows are there?
That's all what this gate item will do.
It'll take the index, say that zero one to whatever it is,
and for that index features
and labels, it'll return means if you'll put the index
number 10, so 10th row, whatever is the features
and label it'll return.
So these are the three functionality I'm writing in
the custom dataset class.
Now, as as, uh, as you're asking, now,
let me create a object.
So this custom, let first run this, okay?
Now here, the custom dataset,
this is the class we have created here.
So I'm just creating object of this particular class. Fine.
Uh, so I'm calling this class for that
and passing what, what this class want.
This class want to feed features and label two things.
So extreme is my training feature
and why train in my training label.
So these two are my feature
and labels for the training time.
I'm feeding as an input and object, which I'm creating.
I'm giving the name, the object as train dataset.
This is the name of the train.
Now, whenever I'll run this one, what will happen,
these two lines will be get automatically executed just
to show that what we can do is
we can put one print statement just to see that,
okay, that is happening.
So this is executed, okay?
Here also, I'll put, let's do so
that this will not get executed print.
This is executed now anyway, so I'm running this one.
Now I'm creating the, uh, object of this particular class.
You will see that, or this is executed.
You can say that in length method
or this is executed in constructor
method that will differentiate which
one is getting executed.
Okay? So now I'll run this one once again,
and as soon I'll run that.
You see that? What is, what is printing?
This is executed in the constructive method.
That means that this is being executed.
I have never called in it explicitly, okay?
I'm also not calling length so far.
I'm also not calling it item so far.
But what has happened, this method,
which is a constructor asset, gets automatically executed.
That's why you are able
to see print statement printing here means these two lines
also would've been executed, okay?
And, uh, but yeah,
the same time, this is not being executed.
Otherwise, you would've seen this printer
statement also here.
That's the difference being this constructed
and constructed method
and any other method in your class, okay?
Right? Uh, uh, is it fine?
Yes, sir. Okay, so now, uh, as you can see
that, uh, uh, we have created one object
of this particular class, and this time I have passed
that extreme wide train.
Now, I will just do it for, so here, uh, it's simply saying
that, okay, 4,800 data points are there
in my trained dataset.
This is the dataset.
What I have for the training,
and these are all the data just to show
that this is the first data where we have the all value,
which means you don't want because
we have already normalized it.
And this is the label for the first data points seven.
So this is an image which has the label seven,
and these are all the pixel values.
Okay? Likewise, we have 4,800
rows in my trained dataset.
Now, similarly we'll do
for test also here you can see custom dataset class.
Again, I'm calling passing this time X test, y test
to test dataset.
Okay? Same thing it'll do. This is the code.
We've got constructor automatically gets called constructed
method is being called.
That's all. Now, this is the work of the dataset class.
Now, the next thing is
to use the data loader class of the tors.
Okay? So we have already inputted pipe,
so you can use it as it is.
So data loader, we are calling,
this is the abstract class in pythons defined already
what we are passing trained dataset and test dataset.
You see that just now we have created passing as an,
as a parameter telling that, okay, how many badge size,
what is, what will be the batch size?
So in every batch there will be 32 rows
or 32 samples data points.
That is what I'm indicating here, and I'm saying that
before creating the batch, you have to shuffle the data.
So suppose I have 4,800 data, 4,800 data.
What I'll do, I'll shuffle this 4,800,
and then I will, I'll just, uh, uh, I'll just restart, uh,
picking the 32 batch wise first 32, second 32.
But because data is suffered, so I'm not, uh, taking only,
uh, data sequentially as it is there in my data, um, uh,
means in the CSV file.
Okay? So shuffle is called to true here.
Same thing I'm doing for the test data.
So creating the badge of 32, but this time shuffle is false.
Why? Because usually for the test data set, I don't want
to shuffle is why, because shuffling has its own problem in
the sense that if you will shuffle, then, uh,
if suppose same data points are not coming in the same
batches, then uh, uh, you will see
that it's a slight variance in the accuracy in every oc.
I just, just want to avoid at the test time
because test time shuffling doesn't mean
because any, suppose I have a hundred data, I want
to pass all the a hundred data
and get, I just have to find what is overall accuracy.
So shuffling, uh, uh, like doesn't, uh, uh, help anywhere
but in the train time shuffling, why it is helpful,
because really data, I feel start picking it is possible
that all one class data will come,
all two class data will come.
Maybe ninth class data will not come
because that is how it is there in the CSV.
That's why at train time, it helps at the test time,
it doesn't help, and it make read some other problem also.
So we have put, shuffle is called pulse. That's all.
So what happened, uh, in the backend, what happens,
you know, whenever you'll call data loader class
and create subject in the backend,
it'll call the dataset class.
In the backend it'll call dataset class.
First of all, it'll execute this method.
It'll call this method. It is, it is written there.
That's why we are using this, uh,
length method in this particular signature.
Otherwise, we would have created our own method
here for the length, right?
But why we are using this, this method,
because data set,
data loader class will call the custom data set, uh,
this particular class and it'll execute the length method.
It'll call it, it is written there.
If you'll go and explore, you will see that one
and it'll first find, okay, how many rows are there,
because it has to create the batches of 32
to support 14 40, 800 row divided by 32.
Those many badges will create, that's why it'll,
and it'll also, once it'll have that,
it'll call this gate item
because for each batch, whatever index it ha data
or road, it requires that it'll pass one by one
to this particular gate item.
It'll fetch that one.
And that is how, in a way, this custom dataset, dataset,
class and data loader class are connected, right?
So that is what is happening when you're writing
these two lines of code.
So it creates the batches of the data, okay?
Batches of the data. That's all.
So this is done with the dataset.
Uh, we have, uh, uh, created also, we have loaded,
also created the badge also everything we have done now.
Now, the next thing, what we have to do is we
Have a quick question here.
Yeah. Yes, sir.
Uh, does this, uh, PyTorch data loader work
for, uh, streaming,
Uh, or training, Uh, streaming?
So streaming feeds. Streaming,
Streaming in the sense,
Uh, streaming feeds, uh, meaning the data comes live,
uh, into the data set.
And then, uh,
I have not used it of any of this case,
and so I'm not very certain that whether it works or not.
Okay? You can check that at least for the, I,
I'm not sure about that, that whether it works
for the training time or three test time, it can work.
Uh, i, I feel so,
but, uh, for training time,
you should have the data set in your, uh, uh,
I think it is fixed there.
Then only you can train. I think so.
I'm not sure about that. You can check. Okay. Yeah.
Okay. So, uh, yeah.
Then, uh, the next thing is one
dataset part we are done with.
The next thing is to create our neural network model.
And as I said, the neural network, which I'm going
to create will look something like this.
We'll have the input layer
where we'll put 7 84 new, uh, inputs.
First serial layer, 1 28,
neuron second hidden layer 64 neuron
and final output layer 10 neurons.
And this hidden layer one,
hidden layer two will use the radio
activation function fine.
This is what I'm going to do again,
when you create this class,
first you create the constructor, okay?
The constructor here in this, uh, neural network class here,
my NN in my class name
and NN module is the module which is already
defined in the class.
So we are just inheriting this class.
This is the constructor here in it.
Whenever you will see, it's a constructor, constructor.
Why do you write? You want something
to get automatically executed.
Now, in this case, when you are defining your neural
network, you want the structure of the neural network
to get automatically created, okay?
You want that. Whatever structure you want to define,
you want this to get automatically created and
whenever, then you will call the forward function.
This is structure will be executed. Okay?
So this, this is the internal blueprint which you want
to get automatically executed.
That's why this constructor is required here.
And to create that one, uh, constructor,
what you requires is the initial thing that, okay,
how many input you're going to feed.
So number of features here will return how many,
what is the input shape?
Okay? Super.
The next line you will see as super, uh, function.in it.
So in it is again, constructor,
but this constructor is not for this class.
This constructor is for the super, that it means
that it's parent class, parent class is this and in module.
So this mo uh, parent class also must have some constructor.
So just to access the, uh, like property,
because we are inheriting everything from our parent.
And if you want to access that one, we are calling
that one using this super.
So this particular line is there, and it is required
because you want to inherit the properties of your parent.
So you have to call this one.
So super is used to call the constructor
of the parent class, and that's why it is being used here.
Fine. So this is kind of essential in the, in the,
when you will create this, uh, uh, class, uh,
like your network class, fine in the, in the
now from the next line onwards, it's, it's easy.
You are using some sequential container, okay?
In the container you say that, that I am having these,
this is how it is going to be,
because there, here in the container, you actually defines
how, how the blueprint
or the structure of my neural network could be.
So you'll say that I'll first have the input,
then I'll have the first hidden layer in the hidden
and layer what happening.
You first do the weighted surplus buy
that is linear operation, then you pass it
through the activation function, okay?
Here, also weighted surplus buy that is a linear operation.
Then again, you pass it through the relu here.
Also weighted surplus buy that is a linear operation.
Pass it through some other, this is
what is happening in this, okay?
Output, output of one hidden layer will act as an input
for the second hidden layer.
Output of second hidden layer will act as an input
for third means final output layer.
Same thing I'm defining here.
I'm creating one, uh, model, uh, right of the sequential
of the sequential container.
Sequential container
because things, what I'm going
to write will be in a sequence
or put of one layer will act as an in, uh,
input for the next layer.
So first layer, what I'm adding is linear layer, where
where I'll feed the number of input as number
of features means columns in my dataset,
and it'll connect with the 1 28 neurons, 1 28 neurons here,
7 84 in 2, 1 20.
That is how it'll be connections.
This is a linear operation, weighted some plus bias,
and then it'll followed by activation function, say.
So output of this layer will go as an input to the output of
will go as an input to the next certain layer
where we'll do first linear operation.
So 1 28 output is coming from here.
So 1 28 will be the input in this second hidden layer. Okay?
And then there are 64 neurons in this case,
hidden layer two as you can see.
So 64 will be the output, pass it
through the activation function, relu,
and then 64 neurons are connected with 10 neuron
and 10 are the neurons at the output layer.
Same structure I have created here.
One thing you would be wondering
that why I have not written here and then dot soft max
because I'm using the soft mac activation function.
Okay? So basically when I use the loss function, which is,
I'm going to use here, the cross entropy loss function,
the cross entropy loss function has designed in such a way
that whatever it accept it gets from the linear layer,
it first passes it through the soft max activation function
and then find which prob which
for which neuron it is the highest probability.
So you do need not to write softmax again here
because, uh, cross entropy what you're going to use,
it has already implemented the softmax.
That's why I'm not writing here, okay?
So yeah, in a way, this is what is the structure I want
to create for my neur network and have created
any query in this, in this code,
Sir, at the softmax.
Where is it, sir?
So Softmax will be here when I'm going
to call this cross and ropy laws.
So it has already defined that.
So I will, uh, whatever I'll get from my model, okay,
that I will, uh, output whatever.
I'll get output.
What I'll get, I'll get the neurons output like
neuron will give some output.
That output I'll give to this particular function,
cross entro loss function.
And first what it'll, this function will do,
it'll apply the soft max
and then find the maximum probability for that one.
That is what it is going to do. And then calculate the loss.
Everything is implemented in this one.
If you wanna see that, you can go and explore that one.
You will see that that is implemented in the, okay,
you can go check the So
Does this mean that, um, I mean, um, yes, uh,
cross entropy loss does not, it works only for,
um, sigmoid.
Is it?
Sigmoid is a separate loss.
Uh, sigmoid is a different activation function.
Softmax is different.
Sorry. Yes. I meant softmax, sorry.
So sir, uh, whenever we use this, we have to keep in mind,
or before we use any of these InMail libraries,
we better read and do.
Uh, you read this documentation list.
Okay, that is better. Yeah,
Right? Thank.
Okay, Sir. Uh, I have one question.
Like, uh, the neurons
that this thing will be creating will be perceptrons
or sigmoid neurons,
Uh, perceptron sigmoid neurons.
Uh, what is the meaning of sigmoid neuron according to you?
Yeah, so the activation function will be different, right?
See, I, I said here,
these are all the neurons, okay?
This neuron have two functionality.
Any neurons has two functionality.
First of all, it does the linear operation
that is WX plus B.
Mm-hmm. So X is this input.
W are these weights
and biases connected WX plus B followed
by the activation function.
Okay? So there are two operation linear function, which is,
which is nothing, but WX plus B
and activation function, whatever activation you're using.
So here I said hidden layer one,
hidden layer two will be the activation function
and the output layer, I'll use softmax.
Nowhere. We are using sigmoid in this structure. Okay?
So obviously every neuron has the activation function,
but that is not sigmoid in this case.
Is it clear? It's your choice
what activation function you have to use.
Okay, I'm not using sig mite
because that is not required here.
If I would have the binary classification problem,
then I would've used sig mite rather than soft
max at the output layer.
Okay? You see that first five linear,
which will do WX plus B, then relu, then second in layer,
linear WX plus P, then relu, then output layer linear,
and then softmax is implemented with the loss function.
So I'm not adding that layer here. Yeah.
And this one neurons that it creates, is there any way
to visualize those neurons? Some how?
I have Oh, uh, okay. Yeah, there is a way. There is a way.
So, uh, there is called as.
So I guess then you people have not practiced. Hmm.
So these thing indicate that you have not practiced
what is given to you.
So you are asking otherwise, you have seen that
there is something called, I'll just open that
and show you if it is there.
I think it is available with container and maybe here.
Okay? So the
suggestion is to, uh, just, uh, uh,
practice these notebooks so that you,
so there is something called torch info.
You can install this library
whenever you create any, any, uh, neural network.
You can see it's architecture also.
You can see it's architecture also,
but for that one you can check, you have
to install this torch info if it is not available.
Here I have installed
and from torch in four,
there is one function called a summary.
With this summary, when you'll give the model
and you, if you'll define the input size, it'll give you
that layer wise what is created.
So like how the connections and all are going on.
This is how it'll show you that. Okay?
So you can visualize this one that, okay,
first layer is a linear layer, okay?
Then what is the input? What is the output?
How many parameters are there? Then second layer is a layer.
How many input? What is the output?
How many parameters here?
Third layer is a linear, fourth layer is a sigmoid.
Likewise, you can visualize
and total number of parameters in the whole network.
That also you can visualize,
that you can do here also in this case also. Okay,
Thank you Sir. Yeah.
So, uh, what happened?
Uh, okay, this one we have to execute.
Say that I have executed this,
and, uh, I'll just check this one.
Install, uh, this,
and then input size.
I will then second,
input size is different here.
So input size in our case is, uh, this, uh, 7 84, right?
Or else we can, we can write this. 7 84.
7 84, okay?
And, uh, why?
I had returned here five
because, uh, there was five.
Uh, okay, 10 rows, five columns. Okay?
So here, what we'll do is we'll write, uh, we had six
or 30, 4800 rows.
And how many columns? 7 84 columns.
This is the input size we are giving to the model.
Uh, model is not defined. Where is the model?
Uh, we have not created the object of this. Maybe this one.
We have to push little down after this slide.
Okay? So after this, uh,
this is, okay, so now you see this, this is
what has happened is I have, uh, whatever, uh,
neural network class I have just created.
I've created one object of it.
As soon you will create the object,
constructor will get executed.
This, this structure will get executed.
Right Now with this uh, summary,
what I'm doing is I'm passing this model,
which I have just created.
See there model, we are passing
and I'm telling that, okay, what is the
input which I'm training data shape is.
So 4,800 rows, I've shown you somewhere 4,800 rows.
Train dataset. How many columns? 74 column.
Because those are pixels I have.
So once I have given here a 4,800 rows, 74 column,
it has given me the whole structure.
First layer is a linear layer, and then 4,800 inputs.
Uh, first, uh, 4,800 inputs.
That is what it is going,
and it is connected with here, uh, sorry, not this line.
Uh, this is end to end. It is showing 4,800 input.
10 output, okay? The first layer is this linear layer
where 4,800 inputs are connected with 1 28 neuron.
And that is true also. That is what we decided here.
You can see that the structure here,
okay, so it is showing for all the row 4,800 rows,
but actually, uh, it is 74 in two.
Uh, uh, you can say that, uh, 1 28.
So, uh, okay,
so I cannot changed this.
Input size is only, uh, you can say that the 74,
because 74 is the input which I am feeding
here, okay?
74. And then,
uh, okay, no problem.
So here it requires that only,
but there, so you can see that
what is happening is this is one connection.
It is making, uh, that for all the road,
it is showing that right now.
And then it is, uh, this, this is your second dimension.
That is what you have to observe that 1 28, then 64,
and then 10th, okay?
This is how it is, uh, coming, okay?
And then, uh, one 20, uh, 7 84 into
1 28.
So this is what I can give, yeah.
So there is, uh, this one also. I can give one 20.
No, this is, uh, okay, so this will take that itself,
how many rows it has, and then
how many features we are giving.
So likewise, you can visualize.
I mean, this is how it is,
and it is the same thing what you have done, uh, here, okay?
Alright. So I will just remove these,
but it is available with the other, uh, notebook.
You can check that. You can do a little practice.
So what I've done here is I've created the class here.
I'm setting few more parameters.
A box I'll run for a hundred and learning rate is 0.1, okay?
Because we are going to update those
weights and, uh, biases.
So I'll use this running rate there. Okay, let me run this.
This is fine. Shape is 74. Here.
What we are doing is I'm just calling some of the,
so I'm first of all creating my model.
Just know I showed you earlier also
for my neural network model.
So neural network model, when you have
to call constructor will get called
and through the constructor you require.
Num features means how many columns you're going to feed
as an input that it requires.
So extreme do shape extreme has 4,800 C,
the shape is 4807 84.
This is the shape it has.
And one is written because it'll return you the 7 84.
If you will write here. Zero. It'll return you for row.
How many rows are there? If you'll write one, it'll return.
How many columns are there, right? That is what it requires.
So I will, I'm writing one
because I want to tell you that how many inputs we are going
to feed, it'll create the object means
it'll call the constructor.
That means that it'll create those neural network structure,
what I wanted, right?
And then I will also use loss function.
I'll show you where, but I'm calling the loss function here.
Creating the object of the loss function.
Loss function is also available in the neural network
module, right?
And also make utilize
of this st stochastic gradient descent,
because I'll have to update the parameter.
So this function, again, available in the opti, uh, class
of the tors, it requires all the parameters,
model parameters will return all the
parameters of the entire network.
And with this learning rate, it'll update,
it'll also receive the gradient,
which I'll show you from the backward, backward propagation.
Just creating the object of these three classes.
My neural network, cross entropy
and a stochastic gradient is in.
We are not doing anything. Training is not yet started.
Just creating these things as of know. Okay?
Now train loader is okay.
Now here we have the training loop.
Dataset is done, model architecture, architecture is done.
What are the functions we are going to use?
Classes we are that also we have initiated, okay?
Instant, okay, the created object.
Now there is a training loop. No training means what?
You have a neural network. You want to train that.
So you will train it for number of oc.
So first line, you will see that we have a for loop,
which will run for some number of OC epoc.
We have already defined here a hundred.
So it'll run, the auto loop will run for a hundred times.
Okay? Now, in each OC, I want
to calculate the loss for that epoch.
So this, uh, one variable i, I will be using.
Initially, the loss is zero
because I have not done anything.
And every time the OC will start,
this value will set to zero.
Because for that loss, I don't want
to add the previous OC loss.
Every OC will have its total loss, right? Alright.
Then what we'll do is every OC what I, I need
to process the data batch wise.
That is what we decided. Okay?
So I will fetch the batch features and its labels.
So batch feature, batch label. From where?
From the train loader, train loader we have created here,
you see this train loader, test loader,
we have already created with this batch size to 32.
So batch wise, I want the data in every epoxy.
Suppose I have 4,800 data, how many batch? 4,800.
By, uh, 32, which will be one 50.
Those many batches means order loop will run for.
See that here I've shown also one 50. Okay?
So order loop will run for a hundred times.
Inner Loop will run for one 50 times
because one 50 batches of data in each epoch.
We are, we have created every batch.
I have to run separately.
So in a loop, we'll run for one 50 times in every batch.
What we are doing, we are first calling the forward
pass, forward pass.
How do we call? You call the
model, the neural network model.
What you have created Pass the input.
Input is the batch features. 32 row will go together.
Okay? 7 84 columns.
Uh, okay, for all the 32 row, uh, will go
and it'll calculate the, uh, for each row,
it'll calculate the output.
It'll store where in the outputs.
Then with this outputs, it has the batch label,
correct label available.
It'll call the loss function, loss function.
You remember, I have stored in the variable criteria,
this cross entropy loss function.
I will give the prediction
what I'm getting from in the forward pass.
I'll give the label, actual label, compare
that, calculate the loss.
Okay? Once I have the loss ready,
then I'll do the back propagation.
Okay? So before doing the back propagation, we'll first do,
every time gradient is equal to zero.
Okay? Because gradient value,
the first time you not realize the second time whatever
gradient will come, that should not carry
for the second badge or second oc.
So every time I'm making the, all the gradient
for all the parameters, zero with a zero grad
and calling this backward, backward function.
Backward function will do everything for us.
It'll calculate all the gradients for us, okay?
Based on the loss, loss value, whatever.
So loss dot back backward. We are calling, right?
Once the gradients are calculated, you have
to optimize the parameters.
And for that one optimizer,
and there is a function called step optimizer.
We have already got here from the Optum ct,
just calling the step function.
It'll update all the parameter.
We don't have to write anything, that's all.
So power pass loss calculation, gradient calculation,
and weight optimization.
All the four steps you can see here, that is
what we are doing in the training loop.
How many times? A hundred times out,
one 50 time in the batch.
Those many times it'll happen for every batch first.
First will calculate the, uh, for, uh, for, for,
uh, total loss.
For every, uh, epoch will calculate the total loss.
Sorry, uh, yeah, this, this will get calculated.
Total epoch loss.
And then you will, with that,
you will calculate the average loss divided by total number
of the, uh, whatever is the sample.
That's all. Okay? And, uh, that is all.
Then you are just printing it.
So essentially these are the four step,
and then we are just printing what is the average loss in
that particular epoch.
I'll just run this. We'll see that we'll quickly run.
It'll not take much time,
but the loss is decreasing with every epoch,
with this architecture
and all this, what we have created is it fine?
Any question on this? It is reducing.
You can say that it'll go up
to a hundred EPOCH in every och.
Remember, there are one 50 batches. So one 50 times.
So a hundred into one 50.
Those many times, uh, weight update has happened
and it is done with the 6,000 samples, sorry,
4,800 samples in the train time.
Alright? Now, once we are done with the training,
next thing is to do the evaluation with the test load
or whatever we have created earlier.
So first of all, what we do,
we put our model at the evaluation mode.
Okay? I'll explain that maybe little later.
Why this line is required.
Why to explicitly say the model that now you have
to do the evaluation.
Okay? Uh, there are certain things, uh,
which we do at the train time, don't do at the test time.
And that's why it is explicitly, it is better
to tell the model that now you are at the evaluation mode.
So you should not be doing the same thing
what you're doing at the train time.
Okay. There are certain functionalities, okay,
which I explain new
or maybe in the next, uh, notebook,
the evaluation on the test data.
And here in this loop,
whole loop, we are doing the same thing.
We are saying that at the evaluation time, first of all,
I don't want to calculate any gradient towards do no grade,
no under score gradient.
This is a total number of sample
and out of that how many correct sample that is
what I will calculate and I'll
calculate the accuracy, correct?
By total will gimme the accuracy only one loop.
Batch wise, I will take the input at the test time also
and give it to the model batch feature.
I'll ask, okay, you do the
prediction, it'll gimme the output.
This output, I'll compare.
Uh, first of all, I'll find
because soft max, so I'll find, okay, what is the output?
What is the class of zero to nine?
It is giving to me with this line.
And then I'm, uh, I'll calculate, uh, total number
of data points, which I have got.
And then with this line, what I'm doing is I'm just doing,
checking whether whatever prediction I'm getting
that is equivalent to my batch labels or not.
If it is equal, say that class one, uh,
predictor is class one, batch label is also class one
or whether there's not.
So likewise, we are just, uh,
checking conditional check equivalent or not.
Then we are adding all of them, which are equal. Okay?
Adding into the correct,
which is initially zero, that's all.
And then printing. So what we are doing here is very simple.
First we are doing the prediction from the model,
and then we are checking what of total number of sample,
how many of them are correct,
and then calculating the accuracy based on accuracy.
What is coming here is 83%, and that's all.
So this is what we have in this whole notebook. Okay?
So let me know if you have any
query anywhere.
So we have tried to understand it end to end loaded, uh,
started loading with the data, obviously sample of data.
In this case I, okay,
but then loading data model, building,
training, then validation
of everything we have seen any query,
Sir, is there a way to do this kind
of stuff like building a neural network without using any
or any library like that?
Like hand coding, not possible, right?
Oh my God. So, uh, why?
I was just laughing
because now we are in the fifth week from day one.
We are making a lot of effort to understand s
when we are in the fifth week, you're saying,
is there any other way?
That's why I was like, see, there are ways I would say that,
uh, there are ways where you don't have to write the code,
but I feel that, uh, your motivation
to join this course was to learn these things.
Otherwise you could have learned, uh, those other aspect,
uh, without, uh, having these, uh, EC level of course also.
That is what my understanding is.
But yes, there are some ways, uh,
but uh, that doesn't mean that you should not learn it.
There are some no-code tools.
I don't know whether I mentioned earlier or
No, sir. I'm
actually asking the other thing.
Like I think PyTorch is, uh, abstracting everything away.
So what I'm asking is like, is there a way to do everything
by scratch, by your own?
Oh no, by your own means from the scratch.
Yes, yes, Yes.
Like there is a linear model,
then write the all the WX plus,
Correct, correct. Start
building the neurons and all those things, sir. See,
There is, then there is no way which you require,
you just need to know the python, isn't it?
Because all the equations you can write by your,
I have in the initial days, whatever I was showing you,
the neural that, that we did it from the scratch there.
We did not use any of these neural network module and,
and pythons neural network module
there we were doing from the scratch.
But you can see that, right?
Uh, this, this, this code, you see training loop forward
pul, uh, calculate backward propagation
and up these four lines of code does everything for us.
We would've written there at least 50 lines of code.
If you do it from the scratch, you can do it.
There is no problem. We have done it in the past for the,
for the smaller network,
but doing it for the bigger network and the same thing.
I mean, we have some already, uh, classes available.
You should be knowing what is going behind
that we have already learned.
So you should be doing the practice
and I guess, uh, if you want to do everything
with a scratch, you can do it always, no problem.
Yeah. Okay.
Any other question so far?
If someone who has, see I'm not explaining anything new.
Understand, I'm a, I'm showing you everything.
Uh, with the s whatever we have learned so far, nothing new.
I'm explaining, uh, as conceptual level.
Yes. With, with pieto it looks easy, sir. I mean Ah-huh.
We don't get, yeah, it, it becomes very easy.
So I was thinking like if I have to know
from, uh, deeply, right? Probably
See deeply also we have, uh, explained now, like, uh,
when we were talking about a few weeks earlier,
I showed you, yeah, only with single neuron.
We built that, we wrote all these
codes from the scratch itself.
Only thing is our network, were is smaller that time.
So you have not realized that we are doing that.
Okay? Okay.
So what I suggest that in this, this particular, uh, uh,
when you go through this PyTorch NN module, okay,
so say that.
Okay, here, uh,
before I think the, I think from this,
I am using this NN module, but
before this, whatever I have used,
I have never used NN module of the PyTorch
and I have done, I have written the code
for the neural network from the scratch.
Okay? We wrote the code here for the double express B,
then we pass it through the activation function.
If you can recall, we wrote the code for the sig mite
as well as step function.
We did everything from the scratch already.
I, I am also, that's why I'm introducing this
and in module in the fifth unit, a fifth, fifth week.
Otherwise, uh,
it would've been due in the first week itself.
Yeah, you do the practice from the previous classes, uh,
see the slide, the codes are integrated into that.
Those codes are available. Yeah.
Others, if you have any query,
Sir, uh, where will be the, the practical example of uh,
this one if we have to uh, develop
or write it on our own, can you give any examples,
real life examples that we can practice this,
Uh, real life example means anything which you want to do
with the neural network, you have to write the code like
that, uh, in the sense, right?
For example, now suppose you want
to do the spam identification.
You collect the data from the Gmail,
you collect the data from, say that, uh, uh, um,
e-commerce website
and do the spam classification, which is a
by minding classification problem.
There also, you'll have to develop the neural network there
also, you'll have the data to load, okay?
So everything is dataset, class, dataset loaded, class,
neural network class, everything you have to use there also,
Okay? Yeah. So it'll
predict the class
and then it'll give the results. That's what it does.
Yeah, that's what it's doing here. Also, 10 class problem.
It is, you can see that at last,
I have 10 class predictions.
It's a multi-class classification problem. It is.
Okay, so that is what I was explaining.
We are doing here 10 class problem.
That's why I explained to you that, okay,
what is this data set which I'm using?
So at the last layer, output layer, 10 neurons,
I'm using the structure I'm showing in this.
That's all. Then it is calculating the loss with respect to
that and giving you all these accuracy,
okay?
Okay. Okay.
Uh, you do the practice once or twice
and come with, uh, more dots.
Maybe then it'll be more clear to you if you are, uh,
like right now it is a little confusing also.
Okay? Yeah.
Yes Sir. One question please.
Uh, when to use, uh, the earlier methods, uh,
what we used to do LA in the last semester
and when to use this PyTorch.
Whenever you have neural network, which you have to build,
PyTorch is built for deep learning
or neural network sort of architectures only.
So I suppose you have to implement, say
that only support vector machine.
You should not be using the pi.
PyTorch, I think doesn't have support also for that.
Okay, there, psychic learn has some
of the classes and methods.
You can use that one. So,
but if you ask psych as scale, learn, psyche learn is good
with the conventional pro uh, algorithms, psyche learning,
not good with the deep learning algorithms,
you can develop very initial level of the perception
or some neural network, but,
and where it goes to the deep neural network,
psyche learning not good.
Similarly, pythons is good with a deep learning.
So that is how you can take a call when to use a skill,
learn when to use by, yeah.
Okay. Alright.
Uh, so what I will do is I jump back
to this particular slide now.
So for what I've shown you, I have shown you a sample
of data from this fashion.
60,000 samples are there in the actual train csv,
I've used only 6,000.
Now what I'll do, you, I'll do is I will
show you on the complete dataset how
to do the training 60,000 dataset,
but will you GPU this time?
So whatever, uh, uh, collab we were using
so far we are using CPU,
but now we'll use the GPU some, I think some of you asked,
okay, how this GPU and all is working.
I'll show you today the practically what goes as a theory,
we'll see that some other time.
But GPU as it suggests,
we will have the multiple multi core,
so it can process the data.
Like ly suppose you have batch of 32.
We don't have to process them, say that one by one.
It depends on the number of course what you're available.
You can process them in parallel.
So obviously the training would be faster, right?
That is the main concept, but you can't use the GU
as uh, GPU as it is in PyTorch.
At least that means that, uh, maybe last time I showed
or when we started this course, I have showed
that you can go to the runtime
and you can change this runtime time
and set it to the GPU, set it to the GPU.
But, uh, if you do only this much, it doesn't,
does it not ensure that
or does not, uh, move your whole code into the GPU.
You might be using GPU, but still your code is is in CPU.
That means that in PyTorch, if you want to use really GPU,
you have to set the device at the, at the different,
there are certain changes which you have to do in your code.
That is what I'm going to show you next.
So whole code would be same everything I will, I'm going
to reiterate once again,
but I'll show you little changes here
and there where, uh, when the, the GPU you will, uh,
you, when you will start using the GPU,
what are the changes which is required?
So you see this, so the first change is you have to check
that GPU is available or not.
So you will simply use torch dot device.
This is the function which you have to use in the torch
and it is simply checking if torch, uh, uh, could I, uh, if
to print, could I, if could I is available.
Otherwise it'll print CPU. Okay?
This is the first thing what you have to check, okay?
Obviously when I'll set the runtime
and the GGPU, it should, so GPU is available, right?
Second change I will do at the model level.
So model, when we created my NN model,
we have given the input shape as a feature, as an input.
What we have to do is we have
to move this model to the device.
If we don't do this line, that means
that my model is still on the CPU.
So if you apply the GPU, you have to write this code.
I'll show you that. Okay? Another change.
What we have to do is in the training loop and testing loop
or evaluation loop, we have to move those batches.
What we have created into the GPU.
So GPU name I have left, kept here as device, right?
So here also I'm move moving the model to device.
That's why I'm saying it as a device,
because that is the variable name I'm using.
And here also, when we create batch features,
batch label in train loader,
I'll simply write these two lines of code,
batch features dot two device.
I'm moving that two device, device is my GP U2 device
and saving into the same
variable name, batch feature, batch label.
This is another change, which you have
to do evaluation loop.
Similarly, you have to do that one and that's all.
These are the major one
and uh, other things are just to improve the performance.
The rest of the code would be same.
I'll show you these changes now, okay to you.
So let me open the next code,
and this time I'll use the entire 60,000 data set.
You will see I'm using the 60,000 data set.
I'll just close this
because it doesn't allow more than one
sessions, okay?
Now what I'll do, first of all is I'm just, uh,
connecting this and I'll upload the entire data anyway,
when you'll see this,
oh, okay.
When you'll see this, uh, slide dataset linkage test,
complete dataset, linkage test.
This dataset is little bigger.
1 33 MB data set is still like just a hundred
Voice is getting muted for some time.
Oh, it's connected.
Now I'll use this button again to upload the data.
And I have my data in this anyway,
I've integrated this one to your slide.
You can also have the access of this.
You can download the data and upload.
So here it is being uploaded.
You can see that it has come,
but it is not completed slowly.
It is 1 23 or 33 and b it is total, okay?
Meanwhile, it'll upload and just running few lines of code.
So I'm, again, importing all the packages required
and here the first change, I said, first of all, you have
to check that, check that whether the
GPU is available or not.
Okay? So I'll just run this line
and it'll say that using device coda means
that GPU is available.
Okay? Simple. Then few lines of codes are same,
like I'm upload, uh, reading the data CSV file from the,
uh, from the, uh, using the pandas.
Okay? So it is reading, it is telling that, uh, how many?
29,000. So it is taking some time to load this one, right?
Once it'll load completely, it'll show 60,000 rows
because 60,000 images pixels are there in this data.
I'll show you that. Let it get loaded. Okay?
Uh, just a few more seconds and we'll be done.
So, uh, the
almost everything would be same few
changes, which I have shown you.
That is what I'll show you next.
Otherwise, the code is almost same
guess.
It's done. Yeah, done.
Okay, so now I can, I'll again run this.
I'll just show you how many data points we have now.
So it is 60,000 data means rows 7 85 column.
First column refers to the label.
7 84 columns are referring to my pixels.
Next few lines of code are same.
Here, I'm just prompting few images to show it is an image,
data actual, but available in the form of pixels.
Then converting as a, as an array only thing is 7 84 columns
for x first column
or only one column for Y, which is a label
train test is split doing the same way,
then normalizing the data in the same way.
Okay? Custom data class is same, right? No change here.
See that all the codes are same, no change here.
Then I'm creating the, uh, like object
of this custom dataset passing the trained data.
So trained dataset, test dataset, calling the data loader,
which will convert this data into the batches of 32.
Same thing, okay? Okay.
You can see that now I have 1500, uh, uh, you can see
that the batches, because total number
of data points is 48,000.
48,000 by 32 is 1500, okay?
So those many batches, neural network is same.
No change in the neural network.
You can see that sequential layer
where first I have the sequential container,
then we have the first linear layer, then relu,
linear layer, relu, linear layer, that's all.
Then softmax will be called by the, uh, what is that?
Uh, last function. So model wise, there is no change.
This is also same, a box
and learning is same here also, it is almost same.
Only one line of change you will see in this case.
So my, I'm just creating the object of my model, moving it
to the device, which is my GPU.
That's all. Then cross entropy is same.
Optimizer is same, no change.
That is all one line of change.
You can see here it is creating that one, okay?
Once it'll create that, then is there is a training loop.
Everything is same except this particular line.
This is the only line which we have added
when you have to use the GPU.
So whatever batch we are creating for feature
and label, we have to move it to the device.
We have to move it to the device. Device is my GPU, okay?
So ordered loop will run for a hundred times.
We have set here a hundred inner loop will run 1500 times.
So 1500 in 200, okay?
Those many times weight will get updated for, uh, uh,
per in, in, uh, total number of, uh,
update in the way it will happen those many times.
So you see that it'll take a little time,
but now you remember it is running
for the entire 60,000 samples, not for the 600.
So in a way, it is still faster
because we are using gp, okay?
If you have done the same thing on CPU,
it have taken a lot of time.
So you can see that where a pocket is running
and it is reducing the loss, it'll take some time.
So, okay, so meanwhile we'll come back to this.
Meanwhile, I'll go to the next.
Now, here comes the, uh, evaluation.
So we'll set, uh, the model to the evaluation mode.
Why you still have to wait.
Uh, I'll, I'll explain that part.
So we have to exp we are explicitly saying the model
that now you have to do the evaluation
because I said earlier,
there are few things which we do at the train time,
but don't do at the test time.
So models should be aware of that, that, okay, those things,
which I doing, some
of the things which I was doing at the train time,
I don't have to do at the test time.
Just to that, to, to that awareness.
This is what we have to set.
We are setting that one next line, next piece
of code is, again, same almost.
You can see that only this line is different
and moving the data to the GPU batch to the GPU.
So again, batch feature, batch in the test loader,
we are moving to the device.
Okay? Then just doing the prediction,
finding the maximum probability,
and then checking whether predicted label is equal
to the batch in, uh, labels or not,
and then getting the accuracy,
okay, this is what we are doing.
So our, our, uh, accuracy is 88%.
I'll run it again, although,
but it is, it'll come here at 88%.
What I am doing here is one more line.
This is for the evaluation data
where I have only 1200 data points.
48, sorry, 12,000 data points for 8,000 data points.
Was there with a train out of 60,000.
80% was in the train, 20% in the test.
So this is for the testing or evaluation, whatever you say.
I did the same thing for the train data.
So just to check, okay, what is the testing?
Sorry, training data, training dataset.
So what is the training accuracy?
So testing accuracy came as almost 88% training accuracy.
When I checked it came as 98%.
Now, this is where I want your concentration.
So what I did, I use my same model and pass the features,
but this time it is a train loader
from training data, whatever.
I have trained the model, the same data
I'm passing for the prediction.
So because model has seen these data,
because it's a train data, the accuracy is 98%,
but with the test data, the accuracy was only 88%.
This is where I want you to concentrate a little bit,
and you are, I want you to respond.
If you see this kind of scenario
where the testing accuracy is low
and there is a huge difference, 10% difference as compared
to the training accuracy.
What is that situation called us in machine learning?
Some of you can over fitting over over fitting, yeah.
So you can clearly see
that there is an over fitting which is happening here.
Okay? I mean, this is still running, uh, 77 o'clock.
I'll, I'll run this, these blocks to show you once again,
but this is what you will see.
This is what you will see the observe.
So when we have, uh, in the, what we have done,
the first version I've shown you only sample of dataset.
This is the actual dataset
where I have used entire training, data sample
and training and validation.
What we have divided with the validation equity, 88%
and with the, with the, uh, training, it is 98%.
Now, this is a problem.
Whenever you see this kind of situation, it refers
to the over fitting situation
and over fitting is always, you can say that, uh, bad
for the machine learning, it is good
to have 88% accuracy both at train
and test time, rather than 98% at train time,
but only 88% at train time.
Then your model is not reliable.
So we want the reliable model rather than this training
accuracy is too high and testing is too low, okay?
Now it is done. You see
that my training is done all a hundred p.
So after that I run this
and then you can see that the same thing what I showed,
88.98, and then I will run.
This one also will come similar to that. Okay?
Same thing, 0.98, some values might have changed.
So now I'll take you to the same slide once again.
So what, what can be done?
So obviously we are in the situation of, uh, over fitting
and next thing what we have to do is we have
to reduce this over fitting problem.
We have to reduce this overfit problem.
So what are the object problem tailing accuracy increasing,
we, because loss was decreasing and it went up to 98%.
Validation test activity is saturated at 88%.
So large gap between training and test performance.
Why over fitting happens? Usually it might
be due to these regions.
Fully connected network with many parameters, maybe
no regularization in the sense your model has memorized the
training data, but it is not regularized
for the test data or generalized.
You can say that. Okay?
So this, these are some of the reasons,
and these are some of the solutions
of the, in the dual network.
So one solution is you can add more data,
but we don't have any choice.
We have only 60,000 data. We have utilized everything.
So first, first solution exists,
but that is not applicable in this case.
At least you can reduce the model complexity.
The second solution model complexity in the sense,
suppose you have say that this two hidden layer,
you can make it one hidden layer.
So obviously the complexity will reduce, okay?
Or in each layer, suppose I have 74 neurons,
I could have done, I will use only a hundred neurons, okay?
That we can do, okay?
We can check, but the model here with only two hidden,
hidden layer neurons doesn't considered
as very complex model, okay?
Although you can check what what is the impact of that,
but, uh, uh, you will see
that model complexity if you reduce by reducing the layer
or by reducing the neurons in the layer
may not improve your, uh,
or may not reduce the over fitting
with a significant amount.
So in this, uh, class, uh, I'm not,
I will not show you these two early stopping.
Also, I will postpone it
for the later class to show you, okay?
Wherever you will see that my, uh, training, uh, accuracy,
uh, uh, uh, is being saturated
or validation accuracy is being decorated.
You don't train the model.
I'll show you, uh, earliest topic,
but not in, uh, next notebook,
but with the coming notebook today,
I'll show you three things.
Dropout, batch, normalization, and regularization. Okay?
I have another six minute. I will quickly show you.
It'll not take much time,
although there are some theory, which we, we will go
through it later, but what I will do is
at least I will show you this one, it it'll,
uh, anyway, I've run this, so I'll not run this again.
It'll take more time again, because I have to load the data.
See this one? Now this notebook is a final one for today.
Here I'm importing entire same code, only one or two places.
I have done the change. See import of the package.
GPU setting, checking whether GPU is available, not reading
with the pandas, okay?
60,000 data, all 60,000 data I'm using plotting some
of the data in the form of figures,
dividing the data is trained in test split,
normalizing custom data class, same, okay?
Creating objective custom data class, the data loader,
trained loader, test loader, same neural network.
Now, neural network. When it comes, then that's
where I am making some change.
This is where you have to observe a little.
So what I'm doing is I'm adding few layers.
If you see that in my last, uh, uh, neural network,
I had the model like this linear layer,
then activation function, then linear layer, secondary
and layer radio activation.
Then third means output layer. That's all.
What I'm doing now is I start with the linear layer.
So same number of feature,
it'll accept one 20 neuron is
architecture wise, I'm not changing.
It means not changing the layer,
not changing the neurons, everything.
I'm keeping safe, but I'm here introducing two things.
First one is called badge normalization. Okay?
Badge norm 1D, another one I'm, what I'm adding is dropout.
Okay? Good practices to add the dropout
after the activation of that particular neuron.
Okay? That means that, uh, if you want to add the
dropout here, so what, uh, dropout is like,
you're dropping some of the neurons in that hidden layer.
Say that there are three neurons here.
You're dropping one that is the meaning
of dropout in general, okay?
So when to do that, once you do the linear layer
and uh, uh, do the activation, then you add the dropout
and you just say that how many neurons has to be,
so suppose there are 10 neurons, 30% p equal to zero.
Three 30%, three neurons will be dropped.
That is how the p-value decide
how many neurons will be dropped,
and there is a theory behind it,
which we'll see in the next class or in the coming classes.
But what I'm doing here is I'm doing
the batch normalization.
Why? Because first of all, batch normalization is used.
Something like this. Let me just show you that also quickly.
So here, batch normalization.
So you feed the input to calculate the linear layer
before you will feed it to the activation.
In between you use the batch normalization. Why?
Because you want to normalize everything
before passing it through.
The activation in a way it controls over fitting batch
normalization, and this dropout, they, you, they, they are,
they're being used to control the over fitting.
Maybe in the coming classes.
I'll explain you the theory behind it. One more thing.
What I will be using is called regularization, okay?
Uh, regularization concept, which I'll show you how
to use it with the optimizer.
Okay? So let me go back and show you this quickly.
So here you can see that this is the first layer in
between linear and I'm using batch normalization
after I'm using the dropout.
Now this is the second hidden layer in between,
I'm using batch normalization
after the, I'm using the dropout output layer.
You don't use that because output number
of neurons you don't want to drop.
Okay? That is what is the output.
So that is what is the change in the architecture,
which I'm introducing, and that is the only change here.
So these are the two change.
You can see one batch normalization,
another one is dropout in terms
of the neural network architecture.
One more change is in terms of this optimizer.
Last time I used, when I used optimizer,
I used the model parameters and learning date.
This time I'm adding one more parameter called,
I'll explain that later, no problem.
Now with this three change,
when I did everything else is same, nothing.
It changed in this whole code.
I did again, training and all, uh,
and then, uh, set it to the model evaluation.
Now, what happens at the model evaluation part,
when you set it at the model evaluation, we are telling
that this batch normalization, dropout,
all these are applicable for training time.
At the testing time. You will not apply
dropout at the training time.
You will not do the batch normalization once again. Okay?
That's why this model evaluation is explicitly required just
to indicate that now you are going into the evaluation mode.
Okay? Maybe later I'll explain it once again.
So what I'm going to show you here is once
with this new few changes for the over fitting,
I applied in my neural network
and optimizer for the evaluation data,
my accuracy is same because data was same.
So almost same accuracy. I have got little change.
You can observe here. Earlier it was 0.8, 8, 9, 8.
Later it came 0.8 8, 3 2.
I mean, in fact it had, it reduced a little
bit, but very minor.
But when I checked with the training,
which coming was 98% earlier without this regularization
dropout and all, it was actually reduced to 93.
So in a way, you can say that, sir,
your accuracy is reducing, but I am feeling better.
Why? Because my gap between training
and evaluation has decreased.
So I want my model to be 88%,
but reliable in the sense training
and testing time should be same,
which is still not achieving, which,
which we have still not achieved.
Obviously still there is a 5% gap.
So we have to see some other ways
which we'll see in the coming classes.
But what we have done by adding the dropout,
by adding the batch normalization,
and by adding that D weight decay,
somehow we have controlled 5% in terms of the over fit.
And that is what I wanted to show you.
So before I will say my final words,
I will upload this slide.
I replaced this one with the previous one
and the previous, uh, slide only till this, oh, sorry,
only till this slide were available.
Where, where, where, where, where here
after this, everything is new.
So I replace this, but I want all of you to do the practice
of all these notebook available.
Everything with you.
Note on all the dots, what you have, do a little bit
of tweaking in the code.
Then only you will be able,
because going further, when we'll go into the
C-N-N-R-N-S-D-M transformer, we are going
to utilize same dataset class, same data loader class,
same neural network module class, same optimizer.
It is going to be repetitive.
So one few times in the initially you will
feel that, oh, what is this?
And all later on, everything would look like, okay, it is,
it'll, everything will make sense for you.
So do the early practice so that coming classes,
whenever the next code will come, you will be like familiar
with those, those terms
and all okay with this I'll stop, I'll open for question
and then, then we can stop it.
Yeah. Yes.
So
Yeah. Okay.
Sir, sir, you've shown, you said
that there are 60,000 images in the, uh,
data, correct?
I just, I just, uh, when you are, were showing, uh,
the kale website, I saw there's 70,000 images, ah, out
of which, uh, 60,000 are, uh, training.
Training and, uh, 10,000 are testing.
So you used only 60,000 images here for,
Uh, only one file. I've
used SV.
That's why it in that it was only 60,000. Yeah.
Out, out of these 60,000 images, uh, uh,
hope you use some data for, uh, you know, testing, testing,
evaluation, evaluation, okay,
So that was train test split.
When I was doing, I kept 0.2 test size. Okay?
So 20% top 60,000 with 12,000 was kept for evaluation.
48, it was kept for,
Okay, so, so if, uh, more data is added,
I believe the accuracy gap
between train and testing will reduce
Possible possible, Okay? Okay.
Yeah.
Other questions?
Anyone has any question further?
Uh, this, uh, this particular problem, Eric, uh,
we can solve using classification like, uh, the classical ML
machine learning algorithm also, right?
You can do it, but going further, we'll see that uh,
this deep neural networks are better
because when I'll show you the CNN for the same dataset.
Exactly. We'll build the CN network there,
the performance would be better than this.
A NN. Similarly,
suppose you would've used support vector machine
or any other, uh, convinced
and machine learning algorithm, CNN are have,
have been proven better on the image data.
So we are still work, we are working on the image dataset.
CNN are proven to be better than, uh, the,
it has all performed all the conventional machine learning
algorithm on the image or computer vision task.
That's why we are learning with the A NN.
But quickly we'll shift
to the CNN also once we understand the co conceptual
concept of the CNN.
Yeah, but you can do it, you can try
with any model for that matter.
Doesn't matter. Yeah, check that.
Uh, another question like sir, if we have large set
of this training data
and all those stuff, so is that the criteria
to decide whether to go for conventional approach
or neural network, like the larger data data
that is just towards the neural
networks? Is it something like that?
Yes. Yes. Because neural network data
with the very small amount of data doesn't work.
Well, first of all,
neural networks requires very high amount of data
as compared to the conventional.
This is one gap one, you can say that the differentiator,
there are many other differentiator as well.
Okay? But then the one differentiator is the number
of data points also with say that 500 samples, I mean, uh,
and then will not work well then conventional machine
learning algorithm will be better in those cases
because neural network, because weights
and parameters, that is all it has.
So understand and just understand the pattern in the data,
you need more and more data.
Yeah.
Uh, sir, I have one other doubt. Yes? Yes, please.
Uh, sir, you said one of the, uh, methods for, uh,
avoiding over fitting is dropout drop some
of the neurons in the model,
but, uh, I have the notion that if more neurons are there,
the aggressive, the model would be better.
See, there is a, uh, I have not explained the concept
of dropout in detail, uh, due to the time code, we'll see
that in the coming classes, right?
That what is the intuition behind the dropout? Okay.
Uh, just for, for the quick pointers,
I'll tell you if you know the random forest
in the conventional machine learning algorithm,
there is a algorithm called random forest
or ensemble learning, okay?
Where instead of having a single algorithm
or single model, you have 10, 10 different model data.
You feed it to all the 10 different model.
You ask the prediction from all the 10 different model
and then take the majority voting code.
So in the random forest, what we do, instead
of creating one three, we create say 103,
and we ask from each three, what is the class
for this particular input?
All three will tell, say out of a hundred, 360 will tell.
Class one for three will tell class zero.
So I'll tell that class one is the final class.
So ensemble learning always, uh,
perform better than a single model ensemble model
because they're collections of models
because they're able to observe the variability in the data.
Okay? Now with this added dropout in the neural network,
we are trying to capture somehow the same thing
because in for every badge we drop one
or other neuron, it is not the same
neuron which is being dropped.
So in a way, for every badge we learn different,
different neuron network architecture.
That means that for every badge has seen different
architecture so that they will learn
different aspect of the data.
Next batch, we'll see different aspect of the data.
In a way they start performing a little better.
That is what happened internally. Yeah.
Yeah. Thank you, sir. Thank
You. Yes, yes.
Others?
Uh, yeah. Any questions? I saw attendance was low.
I understand that we have changed the slot maybe
because tomorrow we are busy with the research,
but uh, uh, this class was important.
Uh, so maybe you can just pass this message to others also
to do the practice Okay.
In a group and all let and then come up with the dots.
Next class again, we'll discuss. No problem. Okay.
Alright. So with this, let us stop today.
We'll meet on Monday. Thank you. Thank you,
Sir. Sir,
sir.